[Applause]
did y'all see borah
yes i asked everybody to try to watch
borat that trash ass [ __ ] movie
did y'all watch the whole thing be
honest how could you get it i got
through it you got through the whole
thing
got did you watch hold i got through the
whole thing because you said we have to
watch your [ __ ]
i tried i got through 25 minutes
and i had to turn it off did you see the
giuliani thing
that's the thing worth watching yeah
that was the part that was the main
thing we had to see it
bro i literally i literally [ __ ]
kidding
right you didn't watch the julian kid i
didn't watch that part
real talk real talk i don't even think
he watched 20 minutes oh i swear to god
i watched 20 minutes what happens the
first time that's not good no yeah what
happens the first 30 minutes i swear to
god i watch
what happens first 20 minutes what
happens in the first 30 minutes drops a
bottle and cuts his
foot you know and then he goes to the
hospital
he's like oh my foot my wife those jews
okay first 20 minutes he's you know
locked up he was in kazakhstan they take
him out he's like we want you to deliver
this
monkey to mike pence and then he does
through other things where he sees his
girl or his daughter he meets his
daughter yeah
right and then uh he goes to america and
then the daughter is oh spoiler guy
sorry spoilers yeah
i saw i saw the first 25 minutes okay is
that right i didn't watch that [ __ ]
so it's literally it's literally
unwatchable
if you guys are thinking of watching it
it is mind-boggling how
is mind-boggling how unfunny sasha
baracone is
i was watching it with my girl and she
literally turns to me at one point my
fiance excuse me
and she turns to me at one point she
goes
she goes did we find this funny when we
were kids
it's not as good and there's and i want
to hear you guys thoughts
as to why you thought it wasn't as good
because i i think there's a specific
reason
um but think because you only watch 20
minutes
i want to hear about the giuliani thing
but just just the first 25 minutes and i
turned the [ __ ] thing off it was so
bad
um i think it's he's not funny enough
where if people know that it's a joke
they'll still laugh he's funny enough
where if it's a prank and that person
doesn't know that it's him
we're laughing at that person reacting
to him being serious
but he's not comedically talented enough
to write jokes that permeate
the person being in on the joke the
first 25 minutes
really just showed like people having a
great sense of humor it was like
he was they were like half in on it half
not you know what i mean
i laughed once at the guy at the phone
store
because that guy didn't know what he was
or what he was doing
but anybody that knew what he was into
or got the game more or less
and they were going along with it i was
like this is unwatchable yeah and it
really exposed how like
unfunny he is yeah his real
honestly like the real thing that like
is so amazing about him is
is his balls yeah he's brave he's brave
but his
and i admire bravery don't get me wrong
but his bravery
is mitigated when everybody knows who he
is it's like his career can only hit
a certain level because his career is
based on you
not knowing who he is yeah and once
knowing him is ubiquitous right once we
all know him
you've killed your own career yeah
because you're not funny enough to
actually write jokes that people who
know that you're making jokes will laugh
each character gets like a movie he
doesn't each character gets one movie
and then it's out yeah he does address
that
but in the beginning yeah in the
beginning he tries to everybody knows me
so
the device is i'm going to have my
daughter yes
which will essentially be me but the
daughter can't really live without him
i mean that's why the daughter's like
can i be a journalist too etc and the
jokes are kind of
cause that's the only way you can make
it work exactly but i don't say that
he's not funny enough he's not just not
our kind of fun yeah his funny is his
boss but that is
to be admired and then when he's in that
character he can say funny things
like in the first borat when he asked
the feminist what she believes and she's
like man you know men and women are
equal and then you just laughs in her
face
that's like it's hilarious yes but then
you know the game and you're like oh
this is just what you do you're just
kidding
once you know the characters him it's
like okay there's nothing to do and so
they had to maneuver
around it and the first one that wasn't
the case and that's why it was so funny
because nobody knew and it was brilliant
he was brilliant i used to love watching
him prank the people that was great yeah
but it's no different than any other
prank show like we acted like
i think he likes to see because he's
like an oxford educated dude he likes to
see himself doing like some like
cultural satire
and i see what what he does is no
different than what the elk boys do
like there's this kid who's absolutely
hilarious salim he's on instagram
[ __ ] and he goes up to people and he
moans in their ear oh yeah yeah
that is there's no difference between
moaning in someone's ear in the grocery
store
and like trying to do this like
culturally savvy thing and i'm gonna use
sex
sexism as a as a game to have some meta
joke about how we view women in this
world it's like that wasn't the funny
part
it's just funny that that person doesn't
know that you're making jokes
i i i'm going to put me back a bit go go
go go go go go
yeah it is in the same way that people
in an audience just laugh at
stand-up jokes and like it's funny or
it's not and then we who actually do the
thing are like nah there's more elevated
stuff to this to what we're doing
yeah i think there's more elevated stuff
in the like the character he's playing
is different than just moaning in an ear
as a character now what i don't like
about it is i think he's poking fun at
he's looking down on a lot of people
from kind of a condescending place
and it's like you haven't seen this part
but obviously he's a jewish okay sean
king keep going
the only part that that has jews he goes
into a synagogue and he does his jokes
of like
oh you're the devil please don't eat me
whatever but then he shows the sweetest
most accepting open-minded jewish woman
in the world
she's [ __ ] amazing she's like gila
you love this woman exactly that's the
only depiction you have of a jewish
person and then everything else is jokes
about
middle eastern people and how they hate
women toothless white people
stupid kazakhstanis are i mean like the
fact that he acts like he's doing
something that's like uh
against racism i think his charity is
like stop hate for profit
i don't know if that's sarcasm or not
can you look it up but that's what's on
his twitter
it's stop hate for profit i think it's
his charity and it's just like
that's your life yes your life is
profiting off of hate and like finding
people and making them look the most
hateful as they possibly and if you made
fun of jews too and everybody got that
smoke
hey i can't hate on it so kazakhstanis
i'm surprised wonder how kazakhstanis
feel about
they're pedophiles they incest they [ __ ]
their sister they live in these what's
that
it's not his uh charity but it is like a
movement
it's an actual real movement yeah it's
against like uh
how does against facebook ads but how
detached
can you be like you promote the same
hate you
are facebook all you do is a movie i
think he would say well i'm playing a
character and i don't believe that in
real life but what you're doing is
selecting
selectively editing these clips and
finding ways to make these people look
as racist as they possibly can
as massages as it possibly can as sex as
they possibly can and then cutting
all the stuff that makes people
especially americans because this is
a satire in america americans that don't
look like
that yeah do you know what i mean like
you're cutting every single bit of
footage
that shows yeah americans are pretty
reasonable and they they just don't
really care about your little
there are funny bits within it though if
you it's not nearly as good as the first
one
he was so funny i just want to point out
i thought he was so hilarious
and there were some amazing pieces that
he did yeah in the past
even the who is america stuff i thought
was there were funny sketches i couldn't
get through a lot of who's america
really i didn't see full episode i just
saw sketches he also does expose a lot
of like you're like wow there's some
truly dumb people in america
and those are southerners i don't i feel
bad looking down but you're like wow you
really
believe this [ __ ] huh you're like truly
internet educated you can
find those people in the north too yeah
he just takes tropes
and that's what i don't like because if
like you said if somebody did that with
jews he would feel a certain way
like if somebody did that with muslims
muslims would feel a certain way but
it's so easy to just hand pick groups
that you already have these stereotypes
about and then lean into those
yeah and if it's very low hanging fruit
and i think
the reason why you felt the way you did
was because the first one came out in
2006
yep we were early 20s kids yeah
and the stuff that he was saying was
even way more edgy than this one was
so it's like we're young our brains
aren't as like
awesome no it's it's funny it might not
be
funny say your point like our brains
weren't as like necessarily woke as
we are now so to be a young 20 year old
and you just see this guy just
ripping cultures and being silly about
it and this is on
movie theaters you're like holy [ __ ]
this guy's insane and we're laughing at
the fact that he has so much balls to
say that
type of [ __ ] right now we're looking at
it's like oh this is not
you're not really taking that big of a
risk because now it's like we know
you're just playing a game
and me watching this now it was so bad
because
i see the cuts in it and because i'm on
the production side
so i see half the things that i thought
he was getting away with saying
he isn't he says the [ __ ] after the fact
and then they and then they edited a
regular response
like it's so bad yeah it's so fake and
that's what
pissed me off to respond to that yeah to
respond to that is it like
if he's saying things when they're not
there one
now you lose all the bravery yeah right
and two
you're not representing their response
yeah yeah it's not
real but the first one's like that too i
watched it
so he's a fraud i want the first one
right after and there's times that you
can see when he's talking to somebody
there's a completely different angle and
the the
time of day you can tell like the
lighting is different so yeah
i think he was in a lawsuit i'm pretty
sure over the first one that i'm pretty
sure he was on a bus with a bunch of
kids and they were talking about [ __ ]
and then the kids they were like college
kids at like some
college yeah university south carolina
or something like something like that
southern boys
get some drunk get some drunk and start
saying wild [ __ ] i think they sued him
i think they settled i'm not positive
i remember that but they were like oh i
was baited we didn't get permission to
be whatever like he
entrapped us whatever whatever because
he like the [ __ ] they were saying like a
lot of n word [ __ ] and all that like
was it was it
i don't actually remember them saying
the n word but they were just saying how
like uh
women are lower class citizens they're
just there like one dude was just like
oh i don't respect women i just [ __ ]
them and that's it like
they were saying some real [ __ ]
and it's like the way it's cut it's so
bad
so i think the judge sided with borat
they did
but the point is is like you kind of
gotta be
like a bad person
to do that to somebody and you justify
it through it
through going well look at these evil
people i'm just poking fun at people who
are evil and it's like
well you're kind of putting them in
situations so they're evil
yeah right like they're not going up to
you and saying hey can i say the n-word
on your camera can you promote it to the
entire world you're getting them drunk
and charging them up
and like making them be like fratted out
bros to say stupid [ __ ]
yeah i think you told him like the movie
will never be shown in america you're
lying to them
about what it is like it's like going in
the locker room
recording the conversation and then just
putting it for the world to see
but at the same time you shouldn't say
racist [ __ ] on camera exactly nobody's
no one's giving pushback
real quick no one's giving pushback to
that right you shouldn't be saying this
stuff
but there is something to be said about
a dude who like
just him in general the older i get the
more i realize what a [ __ ]
scumbag this dude sasha baron cohen is
it's like you really are just gonna like
take advantage of people's kindness
especially their kindness in like
bringing you into their home like people
bring them into their home bring them
into their businesses
bring them into their work right like
they welcome him willingly trying to
make him feel uncomfortable
and then he he like sneaks in slimy
sneaks in takes advantage of them makes
them look as bad as they possibly can
to make millions of dollars and ruins
their reputation in their own community
you got to be a horrible like human
being to live with that
and then you go masquerade to stop hate
for profit shut the [ __ ] up
like who the [ __ ] are you you are hate
for profit
yeah he plays on a lot of tropes and i
actually liked certain scenes like he
goes and stays with those dudes who i
was saying like oh they're pretty dumb
yeah but the dudes don't really say
anything racist they're like
death to democrats democrats did this i
don't and maybe i'm misremembering but i
don't remember them being like i thought
that she was about to get
uncomfortably racist and then and it
didn't they hate the [ __ ] out of
democrats
and wuhan might have been started in
china or something like that but not
like
you know these [ __ ] and then racial
slur racial racial slur so it almost
like
i almost looked at it like oh look we're
not as hateful as you think we put up
with a lot of your [ __ ] we invite you
into our home
and we won't have it but we're not as
hateful as you think let me ask you a
question akash how would you feel as an
indian right
yeah if an english person yeah went to
india yeah that's what sasha baron conan
is english went to india
and did a whole [ __ ] movie about how
dumb
indians are how backwards indians are
how racist
how hateful indeed 100 wouldn't like it
100
why do americans why do we let other
[ __ ] outsiders
come into our [ __ ] and become
millionaire and celebrities
clowning us and again the thing that
bothers me the thing i respect about us
is everybody gets smoked
everyone gets smoked i'll make fun of
indians you don't make fun of white
people
that's but that's family business though
that's what i'm saying that's us
and that we could do it because we we
live it we're friends we know each other
who these [ __ ] outsiders coming here
acting like they know our culture
and they're talking about our [ __ ] but
if we were selective if every time you
made an indian joke i was like yo cut
that out of the podcast yo that's not
cool
leave that out don't put that in then
it'd be like yo you're being selective
about who you make fun of [ __ ] you
sasha baron cohen there's a lot of jokes
about anti-semitism and killing jews and
whatever
but he doesn't ever poke [ __ ] you could
poke fun at some stuff in the jewish
culture
everybody could get them jokes that [ __ ]
everybody got them joking i'd be with it
everybody just the [ __ ] he was like
constantly
getting that jews the way he was doing
it it was uncomfortable it was like so
cringy
because he's trying to trigger a
reaction which would agree with it right
yeah and i'm just like like remember he
did that joke about like
how many would kill a gypsy if i want to
kill 20 gypsies with the
tank of gas or whatever like i laughed
at that because it's a crazy thing to
say to somebody it's a crazy line right
it's crazy how the guy just responds
very easily yeah you need the bigger one
yeah you need the bigger but he's in on
the j
he's like i know what you're doing buddy
i'll play this [ __ ] game with you you
know i don't know i just like
to me like there's something wrong with
you bro there's still some ballsy [ __ ]
though
there's no love it's sorry to interrupt
but like there's no love in it bro
like i don't know man like i i think i
come from a place
where i make fun of [ __ ] for a
living
but there's love in it you know what i'm
saying like if i'm making fun of you
you know that there's love like i know
someone about your culture i appreciate
that thing about your culture and you
kind of feel safe with it
right and i'm not trying to do a
comparison thing but like there's love
in that roast
you know and i don't see any love in
this man i don't see him going
i think southern culture is beautiful
and fun and these guys are great
characters and like
i just wanted to showcase how they're
fun but also
showcase some other [ __ ] this is just
you're dumb i wish they showed the punk
moment that would make it a little bit
better oh when they showcase how it's
been
yeah like it just show after the fact
just like hey guys i'm just being silly
with you so i'm like
at least lift that down so i don't feel
bad for that person that you just
used you used bro you know does that
make sense
there's gotta be hard in it there's
gotta be some heart in it bro yeah i
mean it doesn't have to be but like
otherwise it just kind of sits weird bro
i swear to god we put out clips every
week
i i i defy you to find a clip where you
don't see some [ __ ] heart in it bro i
don't care how
this like vicious the roast is
it's not fun for me if i'm making
someone feel horrible man
that's not what i'm into doing i mean
it's like it's like we're roasting we
don't want it because we love
yeah it's not is that's what it's about
that's what we do in this podcast this
is what everybody feels safe
to get made fun of on this podcast y'all
will kill me on this very podcast about
personal [ __ ]
i don't care we just spent the first 10
minutes ripping you
there's some love and it's like when i
see a whole movie there's no
love in it and i know you're making
money off you didn't see the whole movie
you're right
movie with no love in it bro and you're
just making money i'm like oh you're
just profiting off of hate
you're just doing that [ __ ] that you say
you're against bro you should watch the
giuliani [ __ ] though because tell me
about the giuliani [ __ ] break down the
giuliani
you want to help here chime in anything
i miss this girl that's female borett
is interviewing giuliani yep and she's
flirting with him a little bit actually
but giuliani is not at all not with it
and then they go into his room he lays
down on the bed he's like let me get
your name and number starts taking off
his pants
and he's like that's not what he did he
unzips his pants
they go to they go to the bedroom and
she's taking off his uh
microphone so to take off the lapel mic
you have to unbutton your shirt
and then once he buttons his shirt back
he goes
lays back and takes the shirt and tucks
it into his pants it looks like he's
just taking his hands and
going down and grabbing his dick or
whatever the case is but if you really
look at it closely he is tucking his
shirt
yeah that's what i read so he's just an
old man who had to lay back
in order to tuck his shirt and that's
the funny edit in a way that makes him
look like he's gonna do some foul [ __ ]
yeah with shorty and that's what i'm
talking about like yeah they added
another one like they hold hands
but like they i think they held hands in
order to pray or some [ __ ]
but they make it look like he's just
like trying to hold their hands or
something like they're being tricky with
it yeah
and so now you're just lying about it i
don't like that [ __ ] at all that's corny
and that's like
you you're using like camera tricks and
cuts to make yeah that's
the case because i thought he's laying
down most people like you
and most people like you right so it's
just like something you know is [ __ ]
because they never caught any steam
nothing ever happened like right no one
really actually looked at it with any
credibility because they're like yeah
it's probably not that's something that
americans like
and every country should do this but
like yo that's family business if
[ __ ] gonna talk about the
family you better come correct
and if you're using angles and lies and
all this other [ __ ]
to make money off of us talking about
the family i got a little issue with
that man
and you could tell he was even trying to
make it click beatty because
he says no that's my daughter she's 15.
like this girl looks like a woman
and she's interviewing you as like a
[ __ ] news anchor so
why would juliana think in his head that
i'm being interviewed by a 15 year old
girl
but then he like runs in the room he's
like no no that's my daughter she's 15
she's 15 but he's like just saying this
in that moment and giuliani's like
getting he's like he's probably just
startled like what the [ __ ] is going on
you see borat come in with a [ __ ]
g-string or some [ __ ] like that so it's
just a wild moment
and they just try to make it look way
worse than what really happened yeah
why is she taking off his lapel mic
because i just finished the interview
why she that's normal bro like yeah like
sometimes i've had to put lapels on
somebody how many times you've been
at uh mtv film a guy code and then they
take your [ __ ] off like literally every
episode they would take they usually
just hand it to me and i put it on
really they hot they don't hide it for
you specifically with the clothing that
you do or do a specific sticky thing
i usually i usually do it really maybe
there's times that i can't remember but
there's been times i've put on a lapel
mic on someone
and then i definitely asked them like
hey do you want to take this off your
like if it's a woman or whatever
and a dude like you want to take it off
or you want me to put it on like
whatever the case is like
so yes of course she was trying to make
it seem like it was something more than
it is
by touching him and things like that but
it really didn't seem sexual in nature
to me
and he does not be honest about it i
will say he does some creepy [ __ ] where
like
it's like you can't tell if his old man
[ __ ] or if it's him actually being
creepy but he'll like pet her back
like while she he's like sitting there
she like leans over like takes the pell
off and he like
kind of like pats her back a little bit
like right above her butt like it's not
like explicitly sexual but it's kind of
like
i wouldn't want someone doing that to my
girl you know what i mean i'm not
defending giuliani i saw a little bit
just of that because i saw that story
popping up i'm not defending giuliani
again i don't know what yeah he could
not he might be agree he could be a
creed i don't think this
this thing proves it exactly he could be
a creep and it shows that he's a little
creepy
and they could be [ __ ] up in the way
that they edited yeah
that i can yeah both things are wrong is
that fair to say yeah both things can be
true
yeah so it's just like i don't know man
it's a bummer
that [ __ ] was so funny when we
were younger i used to i used to look up
to them
i think it's because we were young real
robbie brought up a funny clip would he
remember the one where um
what was the shorty she was uh the
dancing girl she did like uh
lunell or whatever nah nah nah she was
um it was he was interviewing
this girl she was on like american idol
i think in the beginning
she was one of the judges of american
idol paul abdul
oh yeah and uh the dancing girl that's
no she wasn't known for dancing she was
like really really dancing yeah i don't
know
so he's interviewing her and um
they don't have any chairs in the room
so he brings some mexican dudes in from
outside
and he asks them to go on all fours
and they sit down on the mexicans and
then he starts
interviewing her and the first question
is so how do you feel about human rights
like
that is hilarious that's a hilarious set
piece
uh what was he used to do ali g which is
like maybe
i don't know what the character is
supposed to be but he just interviews
these celebs and just asks the most
ridiculous like a grime like uk
rapper yeah and to be honest i like
i think it's okay to go at celebs with
it because those people are asking for
like exposure they're agreeing to be on
this because they're like oh this will
help propel my fame
yeah right the average person that owns
a [ __ ] like
fish store fishing store if he makes fun
of everybody i'm with it i don't want to
do the thing where it's like oh they're
beneath him so you can't punch down
punch down but punch everywhere punch
[ __ ] everywhere yeah you punch
at your people and them
hey man you punching yeah i guess i i
guess i'm just saying it's easier
it's easier i'm not against punching
down we love punch now it's hilarious
yeah
but uh it's just easier to take
advantage of those people
yeah you know i mean it's just like you
coming in with all these camera crews
and all this [ __ ] you just kind of like
fast talk
them and then get the [ __ ] out of there